[Musique]
anne-cécile de la martinière bonjour un
jour
corinne martin rozès bonjour merci à
toutes les 2 d'arriver en direct de
versailles vous êtes là pour nous
présenter votre notre dernier peut-être
le premier bébé en tant que livre à
savoir un guide qui s'appelle m et
versailles qui est sorti qui sortira
peut-être même demain aux éditions
mardaga donc tout frais est tout nouveau
on va faire connaissance avec vous elle
règne ces six là où êtes vous habitez
versailles et l or comment vous définir
par rapport à ce guide en fait moi j'ai
créé le site
zoom versailles a pour but de valoriser
la vie dans ses aspects solidaire
environnementale et économie locale et
dans ce cadre là on a fait pas mal
d'articles sur justement les bonnes
adresses
et puis toutes les toutes les
entreprises locales est venue l'idée de
faire un guide sur versailles papier
parce que
ça n'existait pas et votre site vous
l'avez créé il ya combien de temps il va
avoir deux ans l'art mois de novembre
d'accord qu'on est un site c'est un site
associatif loi 1901 et j'ai recruté une
douzaine de journalistes et de
photographes qui travaillent sur ce
projet là d'accord donc vous êtes 12 à
vous occuper du site
exactement d'accord alors vous corinne
martin rozès dites moi tout alors moi je
suis là en tant que blogueuse puisqu'en
fait j'ai créé il ya huit ans le blog
grâce à my pocket au jeu l'idée à
l'époque c'était de partager les bonnes
adresses que je trouvais dans la ville
la 8 ans après le blog existe toujours
et je continue à parcourir la ville
inlassablement à la recherche des bonnes
adresses que j'ai envie de partager
c'est un bloc totalement non sponsorisés
ce sont uniquement mes coups de coeur
voilà est complètement le même esprit
que zoom versailles c'est pourquoi
d'ailleurs on s'était rencontrés avec un
c sida quand elle a créé résout mme way
et c'est pour adorer ce même esprit même
esprit c'est à dire aller à la rencontre
des gens qui font bouger les choses
les gens qui ont une vraie démarche
c'est pas c'est un peu comme ça qu'on
travaille donc maintenant une versailles
a pris vraiment l'angle solidarité
environnement et plus beaucoup ces
thématiques
il ya aussi des bonnes adresses moi
c'est plutôt maintenant avec les années
les bonnes adresses
le nouveau restaurant qui ouvre un bar
qui ouvre une boutique mais toujours
avec une vraie démarche
alors cette vraie démarche ça veut dire
que c'est là si par exemple une chaîne
connue ouvre une boutique à versailles
ça m'intéresse pas d'accord voilà où un
restaurant avec un concept marketing et
uniquement ça m'intéresse pas moi j'ai
envie qui est quelqu'un derrière c'est
la personne et la personne qui
n'intéresse a de nouveau fait qu il
exactement
et c'est aussi l'optique de zoom et
c'est pour ça que quand excessive est
venu me proposer parce que c'est elle
qui a eu l'idée du guide et mai puis à
l'heure où ce guide va parler plus tout
à l'heure vous avez mis en commun vos
deux médias ouais voilà
et donc c'est vous qui avez eu l'idée de
ce guide alors c'est assez rigolo c'est
que ce guide donc c'est une édition
belge
et il existe déjà pour d'autres villes
ils sont plutôt des capitales j'ai la
conscience et j'ai un petit peu
prétentieuse s'est pas trouvé non merci
à la chance d'avoir voilà ça parle au
niveau international les tous les gens
connaissent versailles donc du coup
voilà présenté en belgique cette ville
ça avait du sens un pli et dont paris et
surtout il avait commencé l'édition
alors effectivement il ya tokyo
bruxelles genève donc il ya des villes
comme ces international mais ils ont
quand même commencer par charleroi en
belgique qui souffrait d'une image très
négative et du coup quand je leur ai
parlé de versailles en disant facebook
pour aussi rajeunir l'image de la ville
les stéréotypes ont la vie dure sur
versailles
en fait on s'est très bien entendu qu
ils sachent que ça leur a parlé d'un
autre point de vue et faire bouger
l'image de la ville et c'est vrai que on
a eu beaucoup de chance sur deux de
rencontre et c'est cette maison
d'édition
parce que quand j'ai eu l'idée la
première personne que j'ai appelé c'est
corinne en disant je pense que tu as
déjà eu l'idée voilà mais moi oui
c'était c'était vrai mais j'ai demandé
tout le temps en mode opposer souvent la
question quand est ce que vous faites ou
enfin parce que tu fais un guide avec
tout ce que tu connais mon nom de
versailles que vous avez récolté voilà
est en fait je n'avais pas du tout envie
de me lancer en auto-édition là dessus
sont bien trop lourd et puis aussi
j'avais pas vu je n'avais pas trouvé d
il y avait le guide vert l'euro tu as
enfin il ya tout ce type de guide
mais un guide sur la ville elle-même
entre les habitants parce que c'est nous
c'est pas du tout un guide touristique
et ça ça n'existait pas et anne-cécile a
trouvé cette collection qui d'ailleurs
est en train qui est assez récente et
parce que quand je quand j'ai trouvé
cette collection elle existait depuis
six mois on a vraiment été la rencontre
corinna dessus de 10 oui après moi je me
suis battu et la proposer à mon équipe
voilà parce que c'est un projet qui est
sympa à faire en équipe
voilà donc ça c'est faire on avait
vraiment les planètes qui était aligné
une ville qui bouge est des gens qui
avaient envie de le montrer et une
collection qui répondait là est en fête
corinne à raison par rapport à ce qui
existait moi ce que j'ai trouvé hyper
intéressant à l'air maintenant où le
visuel est très important c'était la
seule collection il ya pratiquement la
moitié des adresses quand une photo donc
c'était comme on peut le voir là
derrière et donc du coup pour moi en
tant qu les utilisatrices exactement le
genre de gars que j'aimerais d'avoir
dans les villes c'est à dire un petit
texte très content si qui permettent de
qualifier l'endroit une photo pour avoir
l'état d'esprit
donc c'est vrai que c'est un outil qu'on
peut avoir voilà dans son dans son sac
et tout de suite avoir une vision de la
ville
allez on l'endroit qu'on recherche allez
découvrir grâce à vous alors la
particularité aussi de votre guide c'est
qu'il est écrit à plusieurs mains alors
que les autres je crois sont écrits par
une seule personne qui voit souvent mais
ça a été je pense que c'est aussi la
vraie valeur ajoutée de ce guide lors
que vous êtes nombreuses à ce qu'on me
12 avant la récente projet donc il ya
corinne avec son blog
oui et vous avec votre équipe découvrent
ça y est aussi une troisième personne
qui a joué un rôle important c'est
stéphane et jean gleizes d'actes qui l
avez une expérience dans l'édition et
dans l'édition de guides en particulier
puisqu'elle avait elle s'était occupée
de deux guides sur des villes notamment
sur des guides insolite à l'az évident
la collection des éditions jongleurs
secret n'est pas la part de ces styles
et toutes les racines sont là et donc
avec des photographes et des
journalistes
ouais donc concrètement on sait donc
stéphanie effectivement a joué un grand
rôle avec son expertise
voilà du de l'édition faisait aussi
pourquoi on choisissait une cette
adresse au niveau de la mise en page
quand on a travaillé aussi sur la sur la
mise en page d'accord et concrètement
s'est réuni à 12
autour d'une table j'avais demandé à
chacune de commencer à réfléchir sur
leur adresse et on a travaillé sur un
fichier de 400 adresses donc ça a été
lieu il aurait d'autres restes de sang
donc on a une sur deux il ya eu des
adresses où on a beaucoup discuté il y
avait chacune avait un peu son adresse
fétiche
voilà donc il a fallu faire des
arbitrages on est retourné voir de
certaines dans certaines adresses pour
être sûr à chaque fois peut-être anonyme
que vous y allez évidemment il a au plus
ou moins quand on y arrive
oui après on a pu au moins autant de
blogueuses quand je le fais oui quand
vous me le fais aussi au démarrage
après là au bout d'un moment quand
l'adresse on savait qu'elle allait
figurer dans le guide
on a parlé oui mais au début
effectivement comme le disait corinne
tout à l'heure
on est droit dans mes bottes et des
recettes d'il n'ya pas de copinage où il
n'y a pas de on est on est seulement
investi du fait d'avoir de mettre en
valeur la ville avec ses 200 adresses
qu'on a tout qu'on connaît tout par
coeur qu'on a qu'on est allé voir à
l'ajustement l'en à qui offrir ce guide
acquis le recommandait déjà tout le
monde tous les versaillais
parce que pour l'instant on l'a montré
et je sais pas sur les réactions agacées
ans la loire alors déjà les gens louvre
et ils soient y est
mais le lead in extenso c'est arrivé moi
j'ai des jeunes avec une amie a pas
longtemps et j'avais des généticiens
fallait en fait elle est tellement les
rebelles
et c'est une versaillaise elle a regardé
toutes les pages et donc du coup elle ne
mangeait pas et en fait les gens nous
disent oh la la
j'habite versailles est en fait il ya
tout un tas d adresse que je ne connais
pas flagrant il faut quand même savoir
que versait c'est une ville très étendue
mais plein de quartier complètement dit
exactement
et puis pour peu qu'on travaille ce qui
arrive à cette personne est bien le soir
bon on n'a pas le temps de pâques daudet
en ville comme ça à tous nos deux trois
adresses et oui en levant le retour
qu'on a sur le guide quand on a 95 ou au
fait c'est à dire ah mais ça a l'air
génial je connais pas et ça donne envie
aux gens aussi d'aller dans des adresses
qui dans laquelle n'aurait ma découverte
a découvert autrement donc c'est plutôt
pour l'habitant et pour les gens qui
s'installent les nouveaux arrivés
nouveaux arrivants et aussi pour des
gens qui viennent passer une semaine à
versailles parce qu'elle quand même un
nouveau type de tourisme qui se
développent des individuels qui viennent
à ces gens là qui sont dans les vieilles
biques sur wii ou qui peuvent être à
l'hôtel mais qui sont parfois aussi dans
dans des meublés ou autre qui prend une
semaine pour vraiment se poser dans la
ville enfin je sais que c'est quelque
chose qui se développe mon moi même au
niveau personnel c'est comme ça que
j'aime visiter une ville sous s'immerger
dans la ville est là pour s'immerger
dans la ville c'est idéal parce qu'il ya
tout les toutes les bonnes petites
adresses qui seront pas dans le routard
qui seront pas dans tous les guides
habituels et on peut vivre la ville
comme un habitant d'accès où on peut où
il ya un guerrier un temps fou pour
gagner un temps fou
ouais ouais
c'est vraiment les parfois y at il des
adresses secrètes presque 1 il ya des
galets êtes fait mutuellement découvrir
ah oui il ya une carte à la fin donc sa
paire allégeance ailleurs c'est à ckoi
garde de quoi trois cartes de des
adresses peut-être que montrer la voie
c'est alors on leur donne ce soit à
l'écran la casse et la carte qui
référence en fait toutes les adresses
sont numérotées ouais moi pour avoir
fait cette démarche là dans une annonce
dans une ville que je connaissais pas
avec le guide c'est assez pratique parce
que ça vous permet quand vous êtes dans
une rue de dire ah bah tiens il ya 50 m
j'ai vu m 1 3 anti casseurs donc ça
permet vraiment d'être dans un quartier
de la ville et de se dire bah tiens je
vais faire les trois ou quatre boutiques
qui ne croit que vous allez à part une
version numérique pour les mises à jour
pour ajouter des adresses faire un
deuxième pour l'instant pour l'instant
on est sur du papier parce que je pense
que c'est pour ça qu'il ya un gros
intérêt pour le guide après moi au
départ je pensais pas que moi je
travaille sur le numérique donc je ne
pensais pas que ça allait avoir autant
d'impact sans de travailler sur du
papier est en fait parce que les dents
le dans les éditions il ya deux
collègues des deux de partie de
collections qui marche bien ils
paraissent et des guides et les livres
de cuisine ou en fait les gens ont
encore besoin du sas en papier voilà ça
c'est sûr ça serait sa table de nuit
justement parlant d' offrir ou est-ce
qu'on peut l'acheter de ce guide est
magnifique mais avec 2 est bien dans
toutes les librairies de versailles déjà
et puis on peut le ailleurs le commander
en librairie et je pense que certains
commerçants dont vous parlez le vendront
dans leurs boutiques non pour le
lancement en fait on a fait nos
meilleurs ambassadeurs
c'est vraiment les meilleurs ingénieurs
juste au moment du lancement mais c'est
vrai que corinne comme moi sont nos
sites
on prône vraiment l'économie locale donc
il est il est disponible sur sur les
grandes plateformes mais on ya librairie
qui vient de fermer cet été à versailles
donc nous c'est vraiment l'engagement
d'aller rencontrer est allé prier en
libre et indépendant dans les libraires
qui seront validées à partir de demain
dans toutes les deux versa il est même
au château et c'est bien mais écoutez
bravo parce que c'était un travail
énorme que vous avez accompli y est on a
tort quand je crois en mars et fin juin
voilà voilà
pour 400 400 cdd badr el c200 finalement
sélectionné la sélection a été ce
portier des bagarres il y avait la
guerre oui à l'idée d'une journée type
était bombe a coûté pas de détails sur
un gros merci et puis grâce à un groupe
à découvrir versailles autrement et voir
que c'est pas la vie le poussiéreuse que
certains imaginent encore un des clichés
à la halle de la martinière corinne
martin rozès merci beaucoup d'être venu
nous présenter votre nouveau bébé qu'on
va découvrir avec une grande joie mais
reviennent la bienvenue a fallu les
filles
il